says she still cannot believe guftavo
petro was elected president of colombia
and that the new vice president will be
a black woman like her
she was displaced from the province of
choco after two of her brothers were
killed
she now lives in sudaboli
where she helps children cope with
poverty and violence
i trust in petro because when he was a
mayor he helped us a lot the need to
transform this country is real year
after year the same politicians and this
country is getting worse each day
many here celebrated
victory late into the night millions of
people have been displaced by the
conflict in colombia and many live in
places like this one in dire conditions
people here are telling me that they're
desperate for reforms that will improve
their lives but delivering on his
promises won't be easy for
pedro as he does not have a majority in
congress and he will have to negotiate
to turn his promises into real change
but not everyone is celebrating
this debate happened just outside
doralina's home it's an example of the
polarization that exists in the country
today
i just hope pedro won't start fighting
with the rich this man told her because
they generate jobs for colombian society
i hope this doesn't become venezuela he
said
petro has promised to fight inequality
raise taxes and renegotiate free trade
agreements he also said he wants
colombia to begin a transition to clean
energy as soon as possible
he clarified during his campaign that
this would be a gradual process
and yet i think it remains to be seen in
a country that is highly dependent um on
natural resources for its income how he
plans to go ahead to promote this
transition which i believe is a very
good one for colombia and for the world
in a viable way that doesn't
mean
putting you know excessive stress on the
economy and it actually allows him to
advance on his more social agenda
pedro has said his priority is to start
working towards long-lasting peace in
the country
even though the colombian government
signed a peace deal with the farc in
2016
some parts of the country continue to
live in conflict
the left-wing rebel group known as the
eln composed of around 2 500 fighters
announced they were ready for talks with
petros government
and that's why people like doralina are
excited about this new beginning for the
country
an era she hopes where dialogue and not
war will prevail
[Music]